das ist das neue buch von oliver wnuk ob
es überhaupt sein erstes buch oliver
fluck ihr kennt denn als ulf aus
stromberg und
entschuldigung oliver als freund von
yvonne catterfeld und er hat ein buch
geschrieben es scheint mir ein wenig
autobiografisch umso spannender ein
interview mit ihm es geht nämlich um das
liebesleben eines hält nicht was gar
nicht wie er heißt tom ich glaube als
der erste und
inzwischen ex frau freundin kind und so
weiter und so fort und wie er damit
umgehen wir hatten ja schon ein super
interview mit ihm und ich glaube wir
können da anknüpfen und außerdem
natürlich wieder spannenden nutzerfragen
im stellen die ihr euch aus denkt
möglichst kreativ einfallsreich
das ist jetzt eigentlich das gleiche
wort gewesen auch egal
postet es am besten als video frage mit
einem button der hier irgendwo im video
ist oder unten im kommentarfeld gegen
daneben taucht dann einen link auf und
lässt unten den infotecs und gibt auch
mal die links an und dann steht eurem
frage erfolg eigentlich nichts mehr im
weg viel glück